hey what's up guys I'm Kay Bhd here and
today we're going to be talking about
why I'm actually excited for the next
iPad the iPad 3 hopefully not the 2s you
guys already know I almost never do
rumor videos but let's just do this one
number one is the Retina display if you
probably already know me mm KB HD and
the HD if you didn't already know stands
for high definition which basically
means I love pixels lots and lots of
pixels so Retina display is actually
something I really liked about the
iPhone 4 and 4s but the screen was a
little bit on the small side but it was
still pretty beautiful apparently Google
agreed because the Samsung Galaxy Nexus
came out and besides everything else
that's awesome about it it has a four
point six five inch 1280 by 720 Full HD
display I love it so high pixel
densities like the Retina display and
other high resolution displays are
inherently awesome and on tablets they
are super awesome
the current rumored resolution on the
iPad 3 is 2048 by 1536 which is exactly
twice the vertical resolution and twice
the horizontal resolution of the current
iPad the iPad 2 which is 1024 by 768 but
that's not twice the pixels if you do
the math basically math people that is
four times the pixels so I'm four times
as happy for that display basic math
people come on number two is the
quad-core processor you may or may not
have seen my review of the quad-core
Asus Transformer Prime if you didn't
I'll summarize it for you in a word or
two it's fast really really really
really fast the iPad 2 is already pretty
fast now I'm not doubting Apple's
ability to make it significantly faster
and to make the user experience
absolutely fly I trust in their AC 5
architecture I think they're going to
call it the a5 X or the a6 one of those
two but either way it's going to be very
very fast I'm excited for quad-core on
tablets and especially in phones coming
up later this year in 2012 so Apple is
typically the flagship for this kind of
stuff bring it on quad-core absolutely
number three actually you know what I
think that's about it I'm not a huge is
guy as you guys probably already know I
will I be picking this up and reviewing
it if I feel it's worthy absolutely I'll
be comparing this
transform prime that I love so much
absolutely if it comes with Siri will I
be asking completely [ __ ] questions
and hoping that I will get a witty
answer that I can post to YouTube
yeah no sorry just now hey thanks for
watching this rumor video guys as you
know I don't always do rumor videos but
when I do I didn't have anything
prepared for that that just kind of
happened well either way thanks for
watching this video and give it a thumbs
up if you enjoyed and I'll talk to you
guys in the next one peace